this is a production of Cornell
University
that'll work I want to say right off the
bat that the project
done for the day has been a super
collaborative effort
between Tony's program John moti who's
an entomology
summer hi John and Alan Taylor Who's A C
technologist
Allen is hosting the Cornell seed
conference today in Geneva which is
going really well so far
the project
is aimed at increasing biodiversity
so I'm going to share like one slide
about why we're trying to do that in
several slides about how we're trying to
do that
and a little bit of pilot data
points about biodiversity
the first is that biodiversity of course
exists at multiple trophic levels which
tend to influence each other
notably increasing the biodiversity of
plant species can also increase the
diversity of other things
such as insects or microbes
Point number two
biodiversity is associated with the
provision of loss of what we call
ecosystem services or sometimes
disservices if you'll forgive a super
hand wavy explanation for this the idea
is roughly that if you have a system
that's characterized by high species
diversity ah sorry it also
functional diversity
lots of different organisms doing lots
of different things and some of these
things are relevant to us so my
agronomic or environmental perspectives
the third point I wanted to make here is
that there are of course a billion ways
to increase diversity on fines
lots of folks who are intimately
familiar with many of these
lots of approaches to increasing
biodiversity have to do with either
increasing the spatial and temporal
diversity of cracks
or of non-profit
these are just focused on the non-profit
side of things
and that's the case for the project I'm
sharing today which is focused on the
establishment of flower strips in the
Agro ecosystem
now there are lots of words for this
practice by flower strips I'm referring
to an area of the farm often along the
field margin or in a fallow area
that's not planted with crops but
instead planted with sort of beneficial
non-craft species
the flower bit of the flower strip
you did at least part of the goal should
be to provide floral resources nectar
and pollen the beneficial insects but
there could absolutely be other goals as
well
because all plants do multiple things
flower strips have numerous
that said three of the best
characterized are pollination biological
control and conservation
hide
if a flower strap establishes
successfully it does create flowers
that's likely to increase the abundance
and diversity of insect pollinators
often yield the substantial benefits for
infant pollinated crops
perhaps what we think of as largely wind
pollinated soybean is a good example
can get a year boost if there are a lot
of insect pollinators around
on the biological control side the idea
is bits if you have a lot of support for
natural enemies of crop pets
you're less likely to have really
damaged and passed outbreaks
this sort of conservation biological
control biological control through
habitat and manipulation is a key
component of lots of integrated Pest
Management strategies
and is only becoming more important in
the context of climate change or
increasing pest invasions
actually one more plug for conservation
because flower strips are a really great
tool for this
a lot of what there is to love about
them is their precision
you can choose the location and density
and species composition of these strikes
so they can be tailored quite
specifically to support particular
plants or insect species that you're
trying to convert serve
all these benefits are pretty awesome
and there's also substantial subsidy
support available from entities like the
USDA nrcs
that said
New York or elsewhere
they do exist don't get me wrong but the
practice is underutilized
there are a couple of them for this
probably
but a few that I think show up again and
again in the literature and in our
conversations with the diverse group of
folks
one problem is that in this part of the
world flower strips are supposed to be
established either in the fall or the
sport
often around the time of the first Frost
or the last frost
the art even more than other parts of
the years Growers are busy and
frequently just don't have time for an
extra field operation
another issue is that in an Ideal World
these strips would probably be
established with specialized equipment
something like a native seed Journal
that's because lots of beneficial
non-cropsies are small or irregular or
otherwise hard
it's possible to plant flower strips in
other ways
for instance by just sort of
broadcasting them over the field area
but that sometimes leads to poor
establishment
so flower strips established this way
might work out well or there might be a
bad return for The Growers time of month
the purpose of our project
is to try to alleviate some of these
challenges through the developments of a
new technology
technology multi-feed via pellet msvp
tier is that if non-crop science can be
agglomerated or molded into pellets that
are the size and shape of a crop seed
then that new pellets can then be
planted with the crop planter that the
grower already owns and in fact already
has out in the field
so this method would be faster deeper
and quicker and also more effective than
existing methods of establishing flower
strips
so what they're developing then we've
needed a steps
and we've chosen to work on molding
common milky seeds into the shape of a
corn feed
corn seed hence the Appellate
we picked common milking because The
Disappearance of milkweed plants from
Agro ecosystems
largely associated with the Advent of
herbicide tolerant crops since the late
90s
is thought to be one of the major
drivers or the major driver depending on
who you ask
of the last
over the same time period
monarchs were in fact just added to the
iucn endangered species left so there's
sort of a unique
to engage growers in the conservation of
this gorgeous and iconic insect
oh there's one
this next slide is the method figure
about how we make the msap these pellets
that are shaped like hot seeds
in the first image I think I've labeled
it part a
the top row is corn seeds on a one
millimeter grid the next one is milky
seed and then that bottom row is
milkweed seeds that have been d-wings
that is we've removed the sort of outer
wing-like portion of the pericard to
make it easier to fit them in the
pellets
the next step in this process is to mix
up a sort of dough composed of inert
filler and binder materials
the fillers are a diatomaceous earth and
wood flour and the binder is
maltodextrin
exactly
so we mix them up into a dough it's like
somewhere between red dough and silly
putty something like that
and then we pack it into these 3D
printed molds that have the dimensions
of craft seeds
we also add milky tea usually about
three of them into the molds
we bake the whole thing and the result
is this pillow that the side shape and
density of a corn seed
in addition the pallet is sturdy enough
to go through a corn planter without
crumbling
and it dissolves when planted in soil so
that the milkweed seedlings can emerge
the simultaneous accomplishment of all
these things is kind of the big Wing
here and it reflects an enormous amount
of work on the part of Alan Taylor's
team
so we do
we've done a variety of greenhouse and
laboratory and outdoor pod experiments
on these but for the sake of time and
coherence I'm just going to chat about
one of them today
the purpose of this experiment is to
test two vectors
first we wanted to know whether
agglomerating milkweed seeds into these
seed pellets
inhibited their germination or growth at
all foreign
we wanted to know how milkweed feelings
behave when growing together
that's because often we're putting
multiple seeds into a single pellet so
multiple cubes would come out and then
there's some Potential from for
intra-specific competition
the multiple seedlings growing together
dimension of this project it's also
interesting sort of from an entomology
perspective
one thing I've learned over the course
of this project is that minor larvae eat
more than you would think like a loss
and they also tend to wander around from
the plants in which they were born
so from a modern productivity
perspective it's a good thing if you can
have a high density of milkweed plants
available to increase the likelihood
that these wandering monarchs will
continue to find the food they need
to test these two factors the
agglomeration bit and the seedling
density bit
we used a completely randomized design
with Seven Trees
inside of the treatment we planted
unpelligencies what we're calling free
seeds
there was a cluster of one to five free
seeds in the center of each class
in the remaining two treatments we
planted mfvp
one mscp contained in each box
and the mCP contained either three or
five milligs
we had 10 replicates and we collected
data on emergence growth and biomass
roughly the experiment looked like this
these photos were taken shortly after
emergence and they showed that whether
we planted a cluster of free seeds or an
mscp containing several fees we got
several milkweed seedlings that grew
close together
we use those little colored bands to
tell them apart
these are some percentage emergence data
so looking at that third column these
data are presented as mean plus or minus
standard error and importantly this is
on a perceived basis
so looking at a treatment in which three
seeds were planted percentage emergence
of 67 percent
would indicate that on average two out
of the three seedlings emerged yeah
so
there's no significant effect of
treatment here
neither the free seed versus mscp thing
nor the seeding density thing affected
percentage emergence
likewise there's no effect on time to
emergence
maybe numerically delayed a bit with the
mscp but it's not statistically
significant
and height data
here we do have a significant effect of
treatment
s plants and functions notably the light
green one free seed treatment that is we
planted a Single Seed in these pots
grew faster
on the under other end of the spectrum
plant height increased most slowly in
the S4 and F5 treatments in the dark
blue so these are treatments in which we
planted four or five free seeds
this is best explained as a difference
of intra-specific competition it's
easier to get tall when you have fewer
Neighbors
specifically I think this is mostly
competition for water
there's no evidence that agglomerating
the seeds into mscp had any effect on
the height trajectory
so no evidence that this seedling method
somehow damaged the seeds or change
their developments
on a side note
stared at these points every day for
about three months
and at the end of this they'd achieved a
grand total of about 12 centimeters
these are definitely a slow growing
perennial type of plant which is why
they need the help to re-establish an
agile ecosystem
and also why we're not super concerned
about them behaving as weeds in systems
that are frequently Disturbed
all right moving on to plant biomass
so in these figures the black bars go
upwards and they represent above ground
biomass
and the gray bars go downwards and they
represent below ground that root biomass
IMs as a total across all the seedlings
that treatments had no effects on
biology
on the right in Part B we're looking at
biomass by the number of live plants in
the pots at the time apart
so this is sort of the combined effect
of the treatments and the emergence and
any mortality that occurred
again no effect on the above ground
biomass
however below ground biomass for the pot
tended to be greater when there were
more live plants in the pot
now the bottom row here is going to be
biomass per plant
treatment did have a effect on below
ground biomass
and the number of live plants affected
both above ground and below ground
biomass
generally speaking plants with fewer
neighbors grew bigger presumably because
they add more access to resources
again this is a pretty typical effect of
interest-specific competition but
there's no evidence that agglomeration
into nscp did anything at all
functionally it seems like a cluster of
three free seeds is the same thing as an
msep that contains three seeds and the
cluster of five three seeds is the same
thing as an mscp would buy
that's the main thing I want to share
here but I'll quickly note that we did
see Monarch larva in all treatments and
all treatments exhibited evidence of a
Rivery
because this is a single array of pots
it's not actually the right way to
assess modern preference or performance
but this is early evidence that
agglomeration into the mscp does not
somehow inhibit or deter monarchs from
laying their eggs or eating the Milky
plants
inclusions
so we have developed this new technology
which we're calling multi-seed via
pellets mscp
it's intended to increase agro-ecosystem
biodiversity by making it more efficient
to establish these flower strips
in the experiment here today and several
others we've seen no evidence that
agglomeration in the nscp inhibits
emergence from two centimeters depth
growth or Monarch productivity
so we're looking towards scale right now
we're hoping to pursue field trials when
spring 2023
we're also hoping to introduce a wider
variety of non-prop species into the
system
to me a lot of the promise of this
technology technology lies in its
potential to support really a diverse
array of species that we might want to
introduce into agro-equosystems
ultimately Growers could choose tailored
food mixes that would be psychostepic to
achieve their ecological goals
I want to reiterate this is very much
the collective effort of um MST members
Matthew Michael in addition to John and
Tony
we're also so grateful for those who
have helped with the molding and with
the experiments and for multi-state
funding I would love to chat I don't
know if we're doing questions now or
later but I'm also available to talk
anytime thank you so much
why don't we take a couple of questions
well you know you might still have those
rushing your minds and then we'll go to
the next or next week or Cara and we can
certainly come back to questions that
people have more so any questions and if
you could repeat that for those on Zoom
that would be good
questions yes please
of these molded Seas
how long can they be stored
this is a question for Ellen basically
but at least a couple of months and
potentially much longer we haven't seen
any evidence that they lose stability
in particular we've been stratifying the
seeds about two weeks at four degrees
Celsius before placing them into the
mscp
and it appears that once the seeds are
stratified you know once we've broken
that dormancy and gotten them ready to
germinate they do stay up just promising
from a distribution standpoint
I did not repeat the question
foreign
grows pretty slowly what are your
concerns about it being basically out
computed by a crop like corn which grows
quite tall and shaded out
absolutely so the question is what are
the concerns about milkweed being
outcomputed by a crab like corn
and I think to some extent that it
depends on where it would be planted
like I often Envision these steps as
being planted along corn fields so
they'd be less in direct competition
with the crops and perhaps more in
competition with weeds
that is in itself you know a pretty
major issue something like a first year
mowing at perhaps 10 centimeters
would help a lot especially if these
chips were intended to be maintained for
a period of about three years
it's also absolutely possible to use
this technology to do something like
plant a low density of milkweed
seedlings among corn plants
that's unlikely to reduce crop yields
given the relative growth trajectories
of corn and milkweed I have done an
experiment on their competition and the
takeaway was basically they don't
compete corn is much much much larger
plants
I think that one might have to boost the
seating density of the milkweed to some
extent
however what a promising thing here is
that monarchs are really quite good at
seeking out milkweed and using whatever
is available
there are some really interesting
literature on the facts
that even if there's a low density of
very small milkweed plants in corn or
soybean fields the monarchs will find
them to be successfully
so that's potentially promising as well
I hope that was helpful at all bit
rambly
great I think we'll we'll stop there so
that we can get pure events let's thank
Sophie again
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu